I am the executive director of the
Republican Study Committee which is the
biggest full spectrum conservative
caucus in the house of representatives
one of those influential classes I took
at Hillsdale College was dr. Arnn
statesmanship class it really whetted my
appetite for politics in dr. iron
statesmanship class we sort of learned
the basic tenants of the American
Founding I get to spend every day
fighting for those basic principles
Forbes contacted me in November that i
was on a short list for 30 under 30 I
was honored just to be considered and
surprised to be picked forbes 30 under
30 was looking for folks who were trying
to make an impact in the political world
that's certainly what I wake up every
day to do I'm grateful for Hillsdale
College for the people who donate make
it possible for the professors who have
dedicated their careers to teaching I
know a lot of professors like to be a
big research institutions where they
have the least amount of contact with
students possible hillsdale is the
opposite of that and so I'm grateful for
the professors who have dedicated their
career do investing in and teaching the
next generation